[MUSIC PLAYING]
TARIQ SHAUKAT: All right.
Good afternoon, everybody.
I have, as Diane mentioned,
the coveted before-lunch spot.
So thank you to Allison
and the organizers here.
There's a study
out of Israel-- I
think this was published
five years ago, maybe four
years ago-- that looked
at parole rulings
by the time of the day and
basically showed that when
you get right before
the meal break--
right now, where the red arrow
is-- that basically you're just
going to go back to jail.
So you're not getting
a favorable ruling.
So I'm, again,
deeply appreciative.
Thank you, Allison.
So with that said, I
will try and make sure
that we keep this
energized and interesting
and get you off to lunch
shortly thereafter.
But as some of you know,
and Diane just mentioned,
that I am a new hire at Google.
I came in about four
months ago, so I'm still I
think technically a Noogler.
And I came from a traditional
brick and mortar company,
a 77-, 78-year-old company,
Fortune 300 company,
lots of different
properties everywhere,
lots of different lines of
business and a lot of mess,
a lot of what one of
our customers refers
to as the "ugly enterprise,"
a lot of just stuff underneath
the covers when
you looked at IT.
And there are some examples
up here of that messiness.
Legacy applications, in some
cases dating back 40 years,
in some cases dating
back two months.
This whole mix.
Data silos literally everywhere.
We had silos upon silos
and what have you.
And really
importantly a changing
view on the value of data.
There was some data that we
always knew was important.
And there was other data--
video data, for example,
we had no idea what
to do with the data.
And it was expensive
to store it,
so we sort of
threw the data out.
We didn't store it.
It just was purged
quite quickly.
That, obviously, has changed.
There's a lot more that you can
do with that range of data now.
Regulatory environments, and I'm
sure a lot of you in the room
deal with on a daily basis,
bringing the regulators along
as you're trying to innovate.
And then really
importantly, cloud skills
are really hard to find and
really hard to recruit for
and really hard to retain.
And so this was our world.
I expect that this is
a lot of your world.
I see a lot of nodding
heads in the room.
And by the way, as I've been
getting up to speed at Google,
as I've been meeting
with a lot of customers,
I hear this from traditional
"ugly enterprises,"
from the traditional brick
and mortar companies,
and I hear this
from a lot of folks
that we think of as
start-ups that have actually
been evolving the way they
think about their architecture
as well.
Now, the amazing thing for me,
and really what brought me here
to Google, was understanding
when you can even
start to make small dents
in these challenges,
when you can start to
pull out some of the data
and really apply some
real analytics to it,
some real machine
learning to it, et cetera,
you can see amazing
impact on your business.
We managed to bring
down costs, not
just IT cost but marketing cost,
sales cost, operations cost.
We were able to grow revenues.
We were able to really launch
products much more quickly.
And it was all due
to using the cloud
to really unlock
the power that is
locked inside the organization.
So as I come here to
Google, a large part of what
brought me here was this idea
of working with companies
and really helping them to
unlock the value that is hidden
within their companies that
is just sort of trapped
within these silos.
As I've been focusing on what
we call our customer team
and really thinking
about, how do we
work with our customers to
really maximize their success?
There's three areas,
three pillars,
that we are focusing on.
The first is investing
in your success.
The second, which Urs and
others alluded to earlier today,
is around partnership economics.
And the third is taking the
partnership beyond support
into a whole new realm.
And I'd just like to spend
a couple minutes talking
about each of these
different pieces,
starting with investing
in your success.
I think Tim from SNAP said
it just a couple of minutes
ago that when you
move into the cloud
there's a lot of trust involved.
There's a lot of trust involved.
It's a partnership.
It's not a quarter
by quarter thing.
It is something that
really extends much longer
than that, years and decades.
And we at Google are really
focusing on that interface
that we've got with customers.
And our customer team, we're
hiring over 1,000 people
to join the customer team
to really sit and work
with customers to make sure that
it isn't a remote relationship
but it's something that is
really a personal relationship,
because it is a
trust-based endeavor.
Now, really importantly
for us at Google,
as I've talked to customers
what they've really said is,
help me unlock the power of
Google within my company.
Help me get my engineers
connected to your engineers.
And so as you look at
even our customer team,
we're actually focused on hiring
three times as many people
in the technical side as
in the non-technical side,
because the problem
solving that comes
when you can get engineers
connected with other engineers
and really start
to figure out, what
should the workflows look like?
What should the
applications look like?
How do we migrate?
How do we get from
point A to point B?
Well, that is really
powerful, and it's
really dependent on
having people who
want to work with customers.
And by the way, all
of our engineers
are dying to work
with customers.
And we're hiring more and
more who want to do this,
getting them to actually sit
down and understand what's
going on inside the company.
It's not a new build.
It's not a fresh start.
So how do we help you get
from point A to point B?
So that's about scaling.
The other thing that
we're doing is really
looking at the capabilities
that we're bringing to bear.
And these are just a couple
of examples of changes
that we're making, of new
capabilities, new muscle,
that we are building
within Google.
The first is in the
office of the CTO.
So one of the things
that I hear continuously
when I meet with CIOs
and CTOs is, you know,
I need help figuring this out.
I don't just need help
with you explaining to me
what Google does.
I need that as well.
I need to understand
technically.
the security.
I need to understand the
pricing, all of that.
But, really, I also need
help just understanding,
how do I migrate?
How do I manage the board?
How do I manage our CEO?
How do I deal with budgets?
How do I deal with
all of these issues?
So the idea of the
office of the CTO
is to really bring peers
who are familiar with Google
but also familiar with what
it's like to work inside one
of these enterprises to be
advisers to really help you
with your migration.
A second element here
is what we are referring
to as value optimization, or
the value optimization teams
at Google.
And the idea behind
this is, again, it's
a trust-based partnership.
It's a long-term partnership.
And it's one that is predicated
on us partnering with you
to make you successful.
And so we've got teams
in our customer team
who are focused on
reducing your spend on GCP.
Not by saying, please stop
using us or what have you,
but by actually helping to
make you more efficient,
helping where we see
opportunities for you
to save money moving on
to different services,
moving on, optimizing your
application, et cetera.
Now, putting on my sales
hat, because I also
have a lot of sales people,
this isn't the best thing
for a given quarter.
But we're not in this
for the given quarter.
We're in this for the
long-term relationship
and really helping to
make you successful.
And the last piece, which
I'll touch on later,
is professional services.
Now, we had Paul from
Accenture up here.
I want to be very
clear that you will not
see 100,000 Google
professional services
folks running around
trying to serve customers.
That's not what we're in the
personal services game for.
What we are really
focusing on here
is enablement, both
customer enablement
and partner enablement.
How do we actually
develop the IP?
It's one thing to
do it academically.
It's the other thing to
do it with real customers
and then bottle it up
and take it to partners
and help partners understand how
to actually go to market, how
to actually help customers.
It's about training for
our customers developers,
for our partners
developers, et cetera.
So these are all new
skills and new capabilities
that we're really bringing
to market at scale.
But getting to market
at scale is obviously
just one part of this.
And Urs spent a
good amount of time
earlier talking about
in GCP how we've
been thinking about pricing.
I sort of describe this
as partnership economics.
This is something
where, as I mentioned,
our success is your
success and vice versa.
And we need to make
sure that we're actually
delivering our products
and services in a way that
demonstrates that partnership.
Now, one of the
fascinating things
as I started this listening
tour, when I first joined,
is people are obviously
incredibly excited by cloud.
This is a pretty full room.
Lots of people are just
interested in this concept.
They see the idea.
They see the potential that
can be a lot unlocked by moving
to cloud, and they're really
excited about how quickly
the world is moving.
But you keep hearing
these "buts."
You keep hearing the--
but we're kind of worried
that the full
potential of the cloud
is not really being
delivered, particularly
on the economic side.
We've gotten to a
place where I don't
have to own data
centers, which is great,
or, I can tap into services
on demand, which is great,
but you're still sort
of making me figure out,
how do I plan capacity years
in advance, in many cases.
Elements like that, we
think, are under-delivering
on the promise of the cloud.
And so you can look
at a lot of what
we're doing from a business
model and a pricing standpoint
under this umbrella
that Urs refers to
as "putting the
cloud back in cloud."
But really thinking
about, how do we
deliver not just technical
and the capabilities
that the cloud has promised
but also the economics
and the business models
of the cloud as promised?
And you can see this-- I pulled
out some illustrative quotes
from conversations
with different CIOs.
And you can see,
hopefully, some of these
hopefully will
resonate with you.
And we've got some
examples of the solutions
that we've put in place
to try and address
some of these issues.
And I won't read through
each one of them.
I'll let you take a
quick look through them.
But they're fundamentally
these questions
around, how do I
plan, how do I budget,
this idea of penalty
or punishment.
All right?
Customers keep saying,
don't punish me
for actually being more
efficient about how
I'm using GCP.
Don't make me sign
up for something
that if I'm successful I will
end up missing and overpaying
for down the road.
And so a lot of our effort
on the business side
has been in trying
to figure out,
how do we both deliver on
the flexibility of the cloud,
the on-demand of the cloud
reward, long-term commitments
and long-term
relationships, and also
take into account the
total cost of ownership?
We recognize this doesn't
stop at the doors of Google
or the doors of GCP, that
when you're looking at a cloud
migration you look at this
from the context of, how much
am I spending?
How do I manage the
entirety of that budget?
There's no CFO that
I have ever met
who only cares about
this line item,
but you can do whatever
you want on the others.
And so the focus that
we've talked about today
around automation, about
zero ops, around no ops,
is really meant to try and
address that skills gap
but also start to address the
overall total cost of ownership
question.
And we believe that this works.
It's not just solving
individual bit problems,
but when you add it together
what we see continuously
in competitive situation after
a competitive situation is
that this approach, the idea
of sustained-use discounts,
the idea of custom
VMs, et cetera,
can deliver between 20% to
30% lower pricing in aggregate
across the solution than
what you see from other cloud
providers and,
obviously, substantially
lower than many on-prem
solutions as well.
So we're excited by
this because we, again,
think that this not only
is the right thing to do
by the customer and helps us
build trust with the customer,
but we believe that it's
the right way for people
to start migrating
to the cloud and it's
the right expectation
that people
should have from the cloud.
Now, all of this is good if we
can build the relationships,
hopefully have you view
this as a partnership,
hopefully deliver the
ROI and the economics,
not make CFOs hate the cloud,
make CEOs very comfortable
with the fact that
they're operating
in a predictable environment,
in a environment in which we've
got each other's backs.
But as we looked at
that whole equation
and how we deal with customers,
we took a step back and said,
OK, what about that last part?
You've deployed.
You're in the
process of deploying.
You've actually deployed
something in the cloud.
You've taken a lot of risk.
Now your business is
running somewhere else.
How should we be
thinking about support?
Support, fundamentally,
is historically
quite a reactive function.
If something breaks,
we will fix it.
If something breaks, call the
call center, send the e-mail,
do whatever it is that
you do for support,
and we will dig into the
problem and we will help fix it.
And obviously, that's important.
If something breaks
we want it up
and running as
quickly as possible.
What we're trying to do is to
take that concept of support
and really move it to
be beyond the reactive,
to be much more proactive about
helping to prevent problems
from actually happening
in the first place.
And there's a couple of
different elements of this.
I've talked about professional
services and training.
But it's hard to overstate
the emphasis that we're
putting on training
and certification
and really supporting
our customers
as they make this journey.
So today we're announcing
two new certifications
that we've launched.
One for cloud architects
to develop and recognize
professionals who spend
their time working
on developing and building
applications in the cloud.
The second, which we believe
is an industry first,
is around data
engineer certification.
How do you actually
build data solutions?
How do you build ML solutions?
Who's really been trained and
vetted to be able to do that?
So we're excited to
launch those pieces.
And then we recognize
that the one side of this
is certifying people in advance.
The other part is people
like to talk to people.
The idea of, I
have a problem, let
me find somebody
who can help me out.
Well, that, we think,
is really important.
So we're also creating
these environments
where you can get hands-on
dialogue with Google engineers,
not because you've got an
army of people walking around.
We'll also help during
implementations.
But if you're just
working on some code
or you have a
machine-learning problem,
and you've got a bunch
of data scientists
but you really want to
tap into a broader network
to help problem
solve more broadly,
we're creating this Advanced
Solutions Lab, which is really
focused on machine learning.
The idea behind this is that
our customers can work with us.
They can send their
teams from our customers
to sit with Google
machine-learning experts,
and bring your own data
and let's collaboratively
help you solve that
problem, build the model,
tune the models, what have you.
Whatever problem
that you're facing,
we can help take that
to the next level,
or at least be problem-solving
partners in that.
So that's what we're calling
the Advanced Solutions Lab.
About two days ago-- actually, I
think exactly two days ago-- we
cut the ribbon on what we're
calling the Launch Pad.
Launch Pad space here
in San Francisco--
I don't know San
Francisco that well.
I'm told it's a couple
of blocks from here.
If anyone wants to see it
we can certainly get you
the address later on today.
But we did the ribbon-cutting
with the mayor.
Two days ago, this is a space
in which developers can just
come in and meet with other
Google Developers and say,
here's my code,
what do you think?
Here's my code, I'm
having this problem,
can you help me think
through this problem?
How would I do this in GCP?
Questions like that that we
think just sort of starts
to foster not just the
formal interactions
but also gives a vehicle
for the informal.
And we'll be looking as we
prove out the model here
to scale that more broadly.
Now, I'm really excited
to also introduce
this concept of Customer
Reliability Engineering.
So we talked about
training and that
is all about helping your
developers, your partners,
get ahead of the applications
that you're building, again,
to ensure that we're
building reliability
into those applications.
But we realize fundamentally
that the applications
that you're running,
the workloads that
you're moving to
the cloud, to GCP,
it's one thing for us
to say, don't worry,
GCP will be up and running.
But if your app
goes down because
of something that happened
or some misunderstanding
of how to use GCP or what have
you, it doesn't feel very good.
It doesn't feel very
good at all to say, well,
it wasn't our fault. It
was-- your application
was designed poorly.
So the idea behind the
CREs, as we're calling them,
the Customer
Reliability Engineers,
is that they will actually
partner with the customer
and look at your
production applications.
And if a customer wants
it, dig into the code,
put it through the same
production readiness
processes that Google applies
to its own applications that
also run in the cloud.
So you can actually have our
team work with your team on,
is the application developed
right for the cloud?
Are your production
processes correct?
Is your operational
If you want, our pagers will
go off when your pagers go off.
It really is a model of
shared accountability
that we are offering to take
for our customers' applications
running on GCP.
Now, we've got a great
example of this after lunch
with Pokemon GO that
we'll talk about
and how they use CREs to really
get their service to where
it's been.
So I will-- we'll be talking
more about this later
on this afternoon.
But we're very excited by this.
We, again, think
this is something
that is unique in
the cloud world
and unique in the
engineering world.
And we think that
this really changes
the equation of trust between
a provider-- a cloud provider
and a company.
And then finally, I'd
be remiss if I didn't
talk about our
partners and how we
are trying to enable
our partners' networks
to really focus on our customers
and help deliver solutions
with our customers.
13,000 partners
are enrolled to--
and enlisted to help
people on Google Cloud.
And you can see
the names on here.
They range from boutique
firms to the Accenture's,
who you saw up here,
PWC, who's been
a longtime partner of ours,
and the list goes on and on.
And we're very excited
by this ecosystem.
We recognize that we
can't do everything,
that you can't do everything.
And where you want a
partner-- we're not
going to force you to
work with the partners,
but where you want the
partners, what we want to do
is make sure that they are
trusted partners of Google,
that they are trained in how to
use Google Cloud, that they are
trained to support
you in the right way,
that they're enabled
to get access to Google
so that you can enable
that engineer-to-engineer,
product-to-product engagement
that we've been talking about.
And in that spirit, we are
announcing two new partner
programs today as well.
The first is around competency.
So the same idea around
the certifications.
We're really looking
at our partners
and saying that we can
certify that you have
a competency in certain areas.
CINT here is an
example, who we have
certified as having a
competency in machine learning.
And that means that you
can trust with confidence
that Google believes that they
are great partners to work
with you on machine learning.
We've got some more competencies
around app development and data
analytics, and
we'll be rolling out
more and more of
these over time.
And then, obviously,
I think Tim also
from STAT mentioned managed
services as really a big part
of what's going on in cloud.
And we are continuing
to deepen our engagement
with managed service providers.
And you can expect to see
more from us on this, both
in hybrid environments as
well as lift-and-shift types
of environments.
So with that, I spoke
quickly at the end
because I am starting to smell
the dinner-- the lunch that
is awaiting everybody outside.
So to recap, we've
got the three pillars
that we've been
focusing on-- investing
in your success, the true
partnership economics,
and taking the relationship
beyond the support
relationship.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]